[Musik]
eine eu reform bringt die netzgemeinde
auf die barrikaden
jetzt redet unsere grundrechte mit füßen
und ihr habt es ja schon im titel
gelesen und zwar wird es youtube 2009/10
wahrscheinlich nicht abgeschafft wird
nach eu-recht sollen internetplattformen
wie youtube und co jetzt zahlen wenn
ihre inhalte gegen das urheberrecht
verstoßen
die firmen werden auf programme setzen
um das herauszufinden so genannte upload
filter eine maschine entscheidet also ob
ein produkt auf die plattform kommt oder
nicht
für die zukunft bedeutet das einen
riesigen einschnitt in die
meinungsfreiheit im internet und das
würde bedeuten dass plattformen wie
youtube zum beispiel nicht weiter
existieren könnten cdu mann axel voss
hat die reform angestoßen
er sagt schild mal dass jetzt beruhigt
euch mal so schlimm wie ihr das hier
alles darstellt wird das gar nicht weil
es nämlich im grunde nichts anderes ist
als das die großen plattform geld an die
kreativen auch abgeben sollen upload
filter als generationenkonflikt die
digitale jugend fühlt sich nicht mehr
verstanden von der analogen politik und
droht kleiner tipp an alle wähler da
draußen parteien die solche
entscheidungen treffen vielleicht bei
den nächsten wahlen mal abstrafen
so das war nochmal im verlauf frage an
felix von der laden beim klimaschutz
felix geht es ums überleben des planeten
bei dieser urheberrechtsreform geht es
unter anderem um youtube ist es in ihren
augen genauso wichtig dass ich glaube es
geht in erster linie nicht um youtube
sondern um die meinungsfreiheit im
internet und die meinungsvielfalt im
internet und natürlich ist es klar dass
das überleben für uns alle das
wichtigste ist das heißt aber nicht dass
nicht auch andere themen wichtig sind so
wie zum beispiel das gehalt der
kassiererin im bio supermarkt
aber das internet hat in den letzten
jahren in den letzten jahrzehnten immer
mehr an bedeutung gewonnen wir alle
nutzen das internet selbst wenn es
manchmal nicht denken benutzen mich
internet und mich mich stört sehr wenn
nicht wenig aussagen wie die von herrn
voß höre dann stört ich glaube nicht nur
mich sondern große teile meine
generation das komplett fehlende
sachverständnis die klimadebatte ist
sehr kompliziert da wird er braucht
wissen manchmal selbst experten nicht
genau wie man wie man das ganze genau
lösen muss ich glaub bei der
klimadebatte ist klar wo wir hin müssen
aber der weg ist nicht noch nicht ganz
klar
und selbst wenn experten nicht klar
jetzt beim urheberrecht ist es teilweise
liegt es so banal auf der hand dass man
sich wirklich dass man nur wütend werden
kann wenn man wenn man hört dass jemand
der verantwortliche solche gesetzgebung
ist das ganze nicht versteht ich möchte
noch kurz ein zitat richtig stellen weil
ich habe dort gesagt dass youtube nicht
mehr existieren kann das detail ging
noch ein bisschen weiter ich meinte in
der form kann es nicht mehr existieren
denn denn die vom gesetz gefordert nicht
vom gesetz von der eu richtlinie
geforderten inhalte erkennungssoftware
upload filter wir immer sie am ende
heißen sollen die richtlinie ist
komplett schwammig und eben auch total
falsch und mist ich formuliert dass es
wirklich dass jeder dass jeder sagt
vorstände jeder der ein bisschen ahnung
von davon habe ich denke das kann auch
nicht sagen die widerspricht sich selbst
sagt gleichzeitig inhalte müssen erkannt
werden gleichzeitig sagt sie es darf
aber keine massenüberwachung geben aber
das wäre genau das
es ist also wirklich einfach ein
kompletter mist und ebenso wie die
richtigen jetzt aber formuliert ist
könnte youtube eigentlich keine updates
von von nutzern mehr gestatten weil
youtube würde dann dafür haften was
nutzer hochladen und wenn ein nutzer
irgendetwas urheberrechtlich geschütztes
hochlädt dann ist steht youtube
millionenfach in der in einer haftung
und das ist das funktioniert nicht und
und die richtlinie ja aber der richtig
funktioniert wenn sie möchten dass das
installation nicht mehr funktioniert das
sind aber deutlich dass nutzer lage nur
zeitungen etwas etwas raus geben können
und nicht mehr der normale nutzer aber
der kann das nur über plattform ein
normaler nutzer hat nicht die
möglichkeit sich einen server selbst zu
beschaffen eine eigene website
aufzubauen sondern dass solche plattform
angewiesen
das ist irgendwann reigen der
sendereigenen
seine eigenen inhalte ins netz stellt
denn hinter denen niemand daran dass
irgendjemand weiß blauen
ich glaube dass diese versteht der stall
ist nicht das ist kein ist kein total
leichtes thema das verstehe ich aber es
ist einfach zu verstehen ist diese
hätten obwohl die haben keine ahnung
nicht alle politiker die politiker für
durch reden sehr viel ahnung davon haben
und es gibt auch in anderen parteien zum
beispiel eine spd das gibt es menschen
die an den vielen anderen parteien
selbst in der cdu gibt es menschen die
das ganze thema verstehen
ja so ist es ja nicht es ist ja
irgendwie gibt es da einen sprung bei
dem so viele leute nicht nicht ganz
hinterher kommen und diese ist es sich
halt so klar auf der hand dass
plattformen nicht haften werden und wir
haben auch dass wir haben ähnliche fälle
gab ihm ein leistungsschutzrecht dann
nimmt google halt einfach für
deutschland halt erstmal die
entsprechenden vorlagen raus und dann
haben und dann sagen sie und dann sagen
dass kleinere werber der rheinbahn sich
geringere werbeeinnahmen und dann
überlegen sich ob sie nicht vielleicht
ein paar stellen nachbessern
verstehen sie wenn sie wenn wir wie auch
er fest dass in dem kleinen beitrag
gerade erklärt hat dass das hört sich
nicht an für leute die das noch nicht
ganz verstanden haben er sagt ja da muss
ja nur google die haben ja so viel geld
die müssen ja nur ein bisschen was
bezahlen an die urheber aber so
funktioniert das spiel funktioniert das
nicht weil google wird einfach sagen
dass wir werden nicht wenn du wenn ich
irgendetwas hochladen ist vielleicht ich
lade jeden tag ein video auf youtube
praktisch hoch ich bin dafür
verantwortlich ja genau aber ich bin
einfach die richtige die richtige rechte
zu haben ich bezahle auch für rechte an
musik zum beispiel und und ich bin dafür
verantwortlich und nicht google ist
dafür verantwortlich was ich hochladen
das ist ein das ist schwachsinn grosny
und dass google eine verantwortung für
das hat was die verbreiten das finde ich
falsch
wieso sollte ich jetzt eine
verantwortung dafür haben was
irgendjemand hier das kann er nicht
genau sagen weil sie geld damit
verdienen dass die entscheidung nur
schläge damit wirklich verstehen sie das
wenn ich etwas mit der post verschicken
denn er hat nicht die post daran schuld
das ist richtig allerdings ist youtube
und co
das ist ein falsches dass das ist ein
falsches beispiel wenn die post damit
geld verdienen würde dass sie sozusagen
werbung macht dann mit den briefen die
sie verschicken aber sowieso vergessen
auch nicht das sind vergleichen google
verdient nicht normalerweise im
promillebereich vielleicht ja aber
normalerweise nicht an dass
urheberrechtlich geschützten inhalten
sondern google verdient nur ein erneutes
mal selbst wenn der nutzer selbst auf
youtube cent wert wenn der nutzer selbst
werbung schaltet und das kann er nur
wenn er die zinsen dafür hat wenn er sie
nicht hat hat youtube jetzt schon ein
sehr gutes system aus einem upload
filter sehr nahe kommt content id da
gibt's auch viele probleme und da können
sie die politik ansetzen das ganze
besser zu machen und urheber wie mich zu
stärken und musik usw
aber es ist nicht so dass irgendjemand
musikvideos hochlädt und daran irgendwie
google partizipiert aber nicht die
künstler selbst die künstler selbst
laden musik videos hoch für die
reichweite an den werbeeinnahmen
verdienen sie und nur wenn sie selbst
verdienen dann verdient google auch
google verdient nur wenn es jemanden
gibt der auch selbst an diesem videos
verdient machen schalten nicht von sich
aus werbung drauf wir wandern ganz kurz
mal auf die geografisch rechte seite
pauli merck frage die politik will auf
google und co mit einer schrotflinte
schießen und sie treffen das halbe
internet hätte es eine andere lösung
gegeben als die die jetzt auf dem tisch
liegt nämlich ich will versuchen es noch
einmal zu erklären diese upload filter
sind im grunde genommen
automatische zensur maschinen die eben
nicht unterscheiden können zwischen dem
hochgeladenen film oder einer satire
sondern die einfach zensur betreiben und
solche arbeit wie die von philipp von
der laden dann vieles von der laden dann
irgendwie aus dem netz schmeißt hätte es
eine andere lösung gegeben
es gibt dir zumindest eine eine andere
lösung die wir umsetzen können das ist
ja eine richtlinie ist ja kein gesetz wo
das sofort wirkung gegenüber den bürgern
entfaltet und das heißt wir müssen es in
deutschland umsetzen und dann sind ja
viele tausende auf die straße gegangen
auch bei uns vor der parteizentrale und
ich habe gesagt was ist das thema und
habe ja mit den leuten gesprochen und
ihr seid ihr nicht gegen urheberrechte
sondern ihr sagt yao hierbei rechte
schützen weil ihr selbst ja auch zum
teil urheber seite von werken aber die
befürchtung ist dass durch diese
sogenannten upload filter
meinungsfreiheit beschränkt wird weil
ich gar nicht erst die möglichkeit habe
etwas hochzuladen korrigiert mich wenn
ich was falsch und das
die befürchtet keiner hat sich gegen
urheberrechte gewandt sondern um diese
upload filter und es war ja die
situation bei eine kollegin von der spd
frau valerie ist der justizministerinnen
in deutschland hat ihr zugestimmt
für deutschland dass es eben diese uhr
richtig unterdrückung freier mensch also
die karriere das thema ist die aber in
einer koalition ich meine man kann also
ich sage nicht dass das gute natur
bestimmt habe ich kenne sie können nicht
sagen weil diese ja zugestimmt
[Applaus]
die einzige deutsche partei die
praktisch geschlossen gestimmt wir haben
ja spd hat dagegen gestimmt und mich
ganz gut ist wollen wir bei den fakten
bleiben also es gab deswegen sage ich ja
auch die zahl also stimmt die mehrheit
der wähler als partei das ist ja unsere
parteien gruppe hat mit mehrheitlich für
diese richtig aber auch die mehrheit der
sozialdemokraten im europäischen
parlament hat dafür bestimmt solche
zweite mal die frau bali kandidiert als
spitzenkandidatin der spd
und ich finde wenn man minister in
deutschland ist der kann man sich doch
nicht hinstellen und sagen ich bin
dagegen ich habe aber dafür gestimmt ich
bin sonst die cdu sauer mit mir gewesen
habe ich mich gar nicht getraut
also wenn man so ein amt anstrebt muss
man auch wenn man in verschiedener bitte
wenn man von etwas überzeugt ist wenn
etwas seiner meinung entspricht dann
muss ich so abstimmen wie ich es für
richtig halte und nicht sich immer auf
andere parteien beruf aber jetzt zu der
lösung die lösen zudem sei ebenso ja
deswegen haben wir gesagt wir brauchen
habe ich die unsere digital politiker
und unsere innenpolitiker unserer
rechtspolitiker zusammengerufen abgesagt
wie können wir eigentlich das lösen wenn
wir das in deutschland umsetzen und es
gibt ja youtube benutzer jetzt schon
upload filter was tatsächlich manchmal
problematisch ist und wir haben gesagt
wir wollen in deutschland das wie folgt
umsetzen
wir wollen nicht dass irgendwelche
videos nicht hochgeladen werden sondern
jeder der etwas hochlädt da hat das
recht des hochzuladen es muss online
sein und dann unterscheidet muss also
der plattformanbieter sich anschauen ist
zum beispiel etwas mit einer digitalen
signatur versehen das zum beispiel bei
kinofilmen wenn die dort hochgeladen
sind dann wird das gemeldet an den
rechteinhaber und der sagt moment das
ist mein kinofilm das
hast du nicht hochladen und deswegen
muss es entweder gelöscht werden oder er
muss dafür bezahlen und wenn er sagt ich
habe aber das recht irgendwie erworben
diesen kinofilm zu zeigen dann muss er
das klären eben mit dem rechteinhaber
und wenn das geklärt ist kann das
hochland und dann gibt es das was
eigentlich wo es um die meinungsfreiheit
geht wenn ich mal etwas hab ich mich
verstellt haben ja noch nicht ganz
funktioniert nämlich nicht für alle
plattform das funktioniert für kleine
plattform das funktion nicht für
diskussionsforen
es geht hier nicht um youtube das geht
eben um das gesamte internet oder das
große probleme freund befindet sich in
spanien
du hast kommt ich komme hier zum zweiten
teil das war jetzt das was ich dachte
dass ich etwas älter aber wir wollen das
gar nicht hören oder darf ich fragen
habe ich mir schon einmal später ich
habe an dieser stelle einmal ein haken
weil sie schaffe neben den eindruck
vielleicht auch bei zuschauern die sich
nicht ganz genau ausgehen dass
vielleicht gerne gerne lernen möchten
berlin schaffen sie den eindruck dass
sie gerade als cdu eine perfekte lösung
haben aber das ist leider eine
scheinlösung das funktioniert vielleicht
für manche plattform hierzu bestimmt
nicht ganz zurecht
[Applaus]
sie wollen eine lösung vielleicht sagen
wir das noch mal wo ist diese upload
filter nicht gibt wie sie in deutschland
festlegen dass es hier die diese
maschinen diese zensur maschinen nicht
gibt genau
und da sagen nun allerdings fachleute
und juristen dass das nicht möglich sein
mag es ist er zwar zu spät ist falsch
als nation anders macht uns falsch in
dieser richtlinie steht dass dort eben
wo keine lizenzierungs haben
besteht da kommt das was in dieser
richtigen artikel 13
dort niedergeschrieben ist zur geltung
und wir wollen einen lizenzierungsfragen
schaffen das heißt wenn du inhalte
hochlädt und da kommen zum beispiel du
machst das katzen video und dann hast du
musik von irgendeinem künstler dann
zahlst du einen wir schaffen eine
verwertungsgesellschaft übrigens wie wir
bei und jetzt kommt und jetzt kommt wenn
damit werbeeinnahmen generiert werden
dann muss man einen teil der
werbeeinnahmen zahlen an die künstler
die die rechte-inhaber und das finde ich
richtig übrigens haben wir schon nicht
unvernünftig finde ich das schon an wie
in der analogen welt haben wir es
übrigens da haftet der veranstalter
organisiert mal ein schönes stadtfest
letzte band auch eine schülerband
auftreten und die spielt musik von
deutschen künstlern
und die sagen you my heart you're my
soul haben wir selber geschrieben dann
wird die gehen mal sagen stimmt aber gar
nicht und selbst er nicht als
veranstalter des tag habe ich nicht
gewusst haben muss ich zunächst nicht in
das muss auch in der digitalen welt
müssen der rechte geschützt werden und
auch urheberrechte sind wirken den
künstlern schuldig ohne upload filter
ohne einschränkung der meinungsfreiheit
übrigens mit mehr rechtssicherheit für
youtuber und alle die das hochladen
mit all dem zu tun was kann der ganzen
digitalisierungs debatte nämlich völlig
hinten runter fällt ist der enorme
stromverbraucher computer internet ist
der viertgrößte exporteur hat und
sortierte europawahl ernst nehmen
erzählt es weiter wenn 20 prozent
schreiben wir sind das personal in
europa wichtig gerade los werden nicht
mehr ohne umweltschädlich unterwegs zu
sein auch spaß haben
ich wollte stefan aus dazu unbedingt
noch mal fragen zwar hoch interessant
wie auch google und co natürlich werbung
gemacht hat und ängste geschürt hat
gegen diese urheberrechtsreform auf der
anderen seite kann man natürlich auch
sagen auch die verlage haben jetzt nicht
immer durch wahrheiten geglänzt
rechtfertigt irgendwie kann das nicht
beurteilen ob jeder verlag kann wenn
jeder hinsicht da die wahrheit gesagt
das kann ich nicht beurteilen ich bin
aber ganz sicher dass es notwendig ist
dass urheberrechte tatsächlich geschützt
werden und leute die sachen produzieren
ob das filme sind ob das musikstücke
sind ob das artikel sind auf irgendeine
weise daran beteiligt sind dass diese
plattform damit geld verdienen wenn die
das wenn die sich tatsächlich nur so
sehen würden wie die bundespost nicht
dass die sachen verbreiten und nichts
dafür kriegen dann wäre die sache ja in
ordnung aber wissen sie wenn ich eine
kassette wenn ich ja aber für das porto
aber wenn ich wenn ich eine film
kassette haben ich habe eine kneipe und
und ich führe die dvd in der kneipe auf
und dem eintritt dafür denn dann mache
ich mich strafbar oder ich muss das geld
abliefern
das ist doch einfach also da ist nicht
nur einer der vorstellung dass alles
immer frei sein muss von der leyen im
denken ist also immer frei sein muss
eben netz soll ja angeblich alles gratis
sein woher kommen dann also die
milliardengewinne von google und woher
kommen vielleicht auch die einnahmen die
sie haben die sind erklärt
ja ich gehe also ich wer sagt denn dass
im internet alles frei sein muss das
glaube ich nicht der großteil der
demonstranten die auf die straße gehen
und ich glaube ja auch angeblich gesagt
richtig ja ich glaube dass in den
letzten in den letzten jahren wird es
das internet wird erwachsener und auch
die ältere generation versteht langsam
dass man eben auch im internet geld
verdienen kann und es bilden sich
plattformen und es wird immer normaler
dass man nicht nur für seinen fernsehens
oder vielleicht auch stadtfernsehen man
für eine fixe salz body was auch immer
im internet wird auch ganz normal geld
verdient und zwar mit dem ähnlich modell
wie
im print wesen auch nämlich sehr viel
läuft über werbung ich verdiene auch
mein geld über werbung
weil meine und wieder doch auch keiner
nehmen wenn sie irgendeine leistung
bringen
sie verstehen mich weil ich das ist ja
da ist und weiterhin werbung haben und
schalten können und dafür geld verdienen
das doch selbstverständlich die frage
ist doch nur ob diese plattform mit den
inhalten die andere leute hergestellt
haben und die an der dritte person
hochgeladen hat dass die damit geld
verdient so das ist ja im grunde ja
schon wenn die spd sich wenn die spd
jetzt mit macht dann haben wir ganz
schnell in deutschland diese lösung die
die cdu jetzt arbeitet hat glaube ich
ein guter kompromiss
ja ich war auch noch meine ich hatte
eine kürzliche trage ein obdach ist aber
sie wissen dass das internet nicht vor
landesgrenzen halt machen kann und sie
wissen auch dass eu-richtlinien binden
sind und nicht deutschland sagen kann ja
das hat die eu jetzt beschlossen aber
wir machen jetzt mal unser ganz eigenes
ding
diese richtlinie geht eben schon sehr
sagt schon sehr klar dass es eben inhalt
der erkennungssoftware geben muss und
das wird es kann man nicht ganz einfach
als als als deutschland da irgendetwas
anders und die frage ist warum sich
sagen sie jedes nach denen direkt linie
gekommen ist auf einmal damit ankommen
und vielleicht ein bisschen früher im
politischen arbeit selbst wo man auch
als deutschland auch nicht nur als
europapolitiker sondern eben auch
innerhalb der bundesregierung und die
cdu er leitet die regierung und sie
können auch der cdu an
absolut gesehen wir hätten früher sehr
viel vorwissen lösungen finden zwei
fragen überraschen heute freikommen zu
hinterfragen gestellt kann man das ist
diese richtige entspricht das
ausgearbeitet haben die eu richtlinie
ganz klar ja das haben wir mehrfach
überprüfen lassen wir können dazu
umsätzen national das entspricht der
richtlinie weil wir dort ja auch
auslegen können und zweitens wir
schaffen diesen rahmen von der die
eu-richtlinie spricht erster punkte
zweiter punkt ja natürlich macht das
internet nicht an grenzen halt aber das
heißt für uns trotzdem dass wir
natürlich zum beispiel jugendschutz
ernst nehmen dass wir urheberrechte
ernst nehmen nur weil das in anderen
ländern vielleicht nicht der fall ist
können wir nicht sagen na ja das
funktioniert in asien in amerika oder in
irgendeinem land anderen land nicht
heißt es nicht dass wir kein recht
umsetzen wie bei hate speech bei anderen
sachen weil wir davon überzeugt sind
dass es richtig ist okay also die frage
ist dann trotzdem ob sie vielleicht eine
generation verlieren
man auf solchen richtlinien pocht aber
wenn ich das was ich glaube wir gewinnen
sie gerade weil dieser weil wir weil wir
gerade das ernst nehmen also die sorge
um meinungsfreiheit und gleichzeitig
urheberrecht auch von künstlern ernst
nehmen und viele übrigens junge künstler
und schreiben das ist gut dass sich die
cdu auch dafür einsetzen anderes sagen
das ist doch ein guter kompromiss denn
jetzt vorschlägt und wenn wir denen
jetzt gemeinsam mit der spd hinkriegen
dann ist glaube ich viel gewonnen
auch eine junge genau ob sie herzlich
grüßen an formale und hier ist meine
letzte frage
den kann man nicht hatte es richtet sich
immer gegen den staat der protest
richtet sich immer gegen die politik
gegen die eu gegen den staat
man könnte natürlich auch sagen wir
kämpfen dafür dass google und facebook
und microsoft hier endlich steuern
zahlen müssen oder dass es in
ordentlichen datenschutz gibt auch dafür
könntet ihr jacke ich glaube es sind
auch das auch wieder es gibt eine riesen
schnittmenge zwischen den demonstranten
die jetzt gegen artikel 3 10 auf die
straße gegangen ist und den
demonstranten die gegen große große
konzerne wie google auf die straße gehen
würden oder auch sind echt mal ein
großer teil des prozesses wird auch von
der piratenpartei zum beispiel
organisiert die sich eben ganz klar
gegen monopole ausspricht ganz klar
gegen konzerne wie google und zu viele
daten sammeln und ich glaube wir alle
wissen es ist ein riesen problem ist
dass viele internet konzerne fast keine
steuern zahlen
und dass das ganze zumindest nicht bei
uns in europa und vor allem nicht in
deutschland und das ist ein großes
problem und das sollte man natürlich
angehen und auch beim urheberrecht gibt
es gibt es gibt es super viele sachen
die man besser machen könnte und besser
machen sollte es gibt keine leichten
lösungen ich kann ihnen von ganz ganz
vielen problemen erzählen die ich eben
als urheber im internet habe wo ich
möchte dass der gesetzgeber das
vielleicht besser regeln sollte um
plattform zu zwingen das ist besser
regeln einen kleinen nur ein kleines
beispiel wenn ich ein video hochladen
und da zehn sekunden musik drin ist von
einer lizenz sich nicht habe es zum
beispiel ich laufe draußen rum filme
mich selbst was mache ich und im café
nebenan läuft irgendwie musik die raus
pferd das bei mir drin
dann kann jetzt gerade schon kann der
musikverlag klemmt dieses video bekommt
100 prozent der werbeeinnahmen nicht von
diesen zehn sekunden 100 prozent von
allem das ist auch kein zustand und das
ist auch als roadster cdu nicht aber
dass die wirkung
das gerät verspricht müssen wir ganz
schnell einen punkt machen ich darf mich
ganz herzlich bedanken für diese debatte